it's still the Ice Age
grasslands have colonized the landmass
triggering a population explosion
of hoofed animals
the short-faced bear has become the
giant short-faced bear the largest ever
to stalk the earth
it's huge weighing 900 kilos 3.4 meters
tall on two legs it could reach higher
than a basketball hoop
he has evolved a set of lethal weapons
slender legs mean he can run at 50
kilometers per hour faster than most
horses inside his forehead the organ
that controls smell is enlarged allowing
him to sniff out a carcass ten
kilometers away combined with his bone
crushing jaw the giant short-faced bear
looks every inch evolutions ultimate
honeymoon
evolution makes him massive for good
reason
competition for meat on the play is
intense
this guy evolved huge because it needed
to defend itself from other scary
predators like lions wolves when Lions
and wolves were running around the
landscape they lived in packs but short
face bears are actually solitary
creatures so they needed to be huge and
intimidating to defend themselves and
their food the giant short-faced bear
will need its extra size for another
reason
life on the open prairie is about to get
tougher soon
it will face a battle for territory with
a powerful right